dearest Jocko a question for you and the
podcast our fire department promotion
process has role-playing scenarios in
those role-playing scenarios I lose
points because I'm not outwardly
passionate quote-unquote enough I would
have to fake it to succeed and I'm not a
fake person is this worth it to fake it
when seeking promotion it's not like I'm
gonna fake it once I attain the
promotion okay this is a this is a very
cool question like this question a lot
and actually on this guy sent me this
question on Facebook I responded very
quickly and simply my response was play
the game yeah so fake it play the game
and and you know what he wrote back got
it
yeah good for him yeah because what
everybody I think thinks I'm gonna say
is that no you be yourself know the game
up there and act all passionate about
stuff you're you you're hardcore no yeah
play the game now you you because what
you're doing you play the game you you
want to do a good job and you're doing
your job and doing your job doing any
job requires some level of faking it
yeah now does this mean that you're a
fake person no it means that you're
trying to do a good job think if every
time that your boss came in with a dumb
idea and you your reaction was to say
that's a dumb idea yeah is that gonna
get you anywhere or every time a
customer had an idiot edie idiotic
complaint about something you were like
hey you're an idiot
yeah or every time your wife said you
know is this chicken dry and you said
it's drier than a piece of cardboard in
the Sahara Desert it is that is that the
easy would you would you benefit from
that how would that work out the answer
is you would he would not work out well
in any of those cases you have to play
the game
you have to play the game and I know I
know that that's hard and I'll tell you
what I did too
get myself over playing the game I
earned it into a game in my head I was
like I'm gonna build a relationship with
this boss that I don't like I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna build the best relay that's
my game I'm gonna come to become this
guy's bro right
when I was at Officer Candidate School
you got to do the most ridiculous
rules they have these these rules that
you've got to follow that were really
annoying and you know what I did I
executed the rules harder and more
stringently than anybody thought was
even remotely necessary and had fun with
it I played that game I you know if I've
got a peer that maybe I'm competing with
or there's some tension I'm gonna
support them I'm gonna play the game
that's what I'm saying you got to play
the game now does this make me a bad
person or a fake person no why because
you're doing this the reason you're
playing the game the reason you're asked
acting this way is for benevolent
reasons right this this guy at the fire
department he's not trying to get
promoted so that he can usurp the powers
and then take over no he's trying to get
into a position where he can better lead
and serve and and step up and raise
young leaders underneath and that that's
what you're trying to do you're not
trying to sneak into a position you
don't deserve and you're not trying to
build relationships so you can take
advantage of people for your own benefit
that that would be a fake person yeah in
my opinion you're trying to move but if
you're trying to move up in rank so you
can do better and you can take care of
the troops and you can increase
readiness there's nothing wrong with
that and if you don't play the game just
at some level you you're not gonna get
promoted and guess what then people that
played the game that might be less less
qualified to do that job they're gonna
get the job because you wouldn't play
the game you're too stubborn your ego is
too big so you got to put that aside and
I'll tell you something else
from what you're being told hmm if if
you're showing no passion if you're
showing like a zero motion that's bad
people will not connect with you and if
they don't connect with you they don't
follow you if they don't connect with
you you're not building relationships
with people if you don't have
relationships with people you don't have
a good team so show a little bit of
passion sometimes you got to fake it
that's fine you're just a really
unpassed at person cool show a little
bit of passion mmm fake it a little bit
learn it a little bit yeah that's
actually gonna be beneficial I would
love for you to fake it for a little
while until you you start caring what
like what are you not passionate about
are you not passionate about the job are
you not passionate about you're a
firefighter about saving people's lives
are you not passionate about having a
squared-away Department you of course
you're passionate about that stuff
otherwise you wouldn't be you wouldn't
be send me a message saying hey how do I
get advanced how do i how do I do better
yeah you are passionate about it and
that's fine it's good I say it all the
time you know if you don't have any
emotions that you're a robot and robots
people don't follow robots you so
sometimes you got to show a little bit
of that emotion and passion to connect
with people that's okay yeah don't be
scared homey yeah yeah cuz that's really
the thing right is showing it of course
you're passionate about but showing it
there's different people there something
Brian I dig it
yeah I wanna always be like showing how
fired up I am all the time or whatever
in whatever scenario whatever but you're
right that does help there like when he
was excited about this it's and there's
a there's a dichotomy here yeah because
there's some people that will show too
much emotions yeah and there's some
people that will not show enough so you
want to be somewhere balanced in the
middle yeah and I dig it too one because
it does feel like faking it because I
can in football that tradition is like
to be fired up on the sidelines and
let's go let's go you know like that can
bring sometimes gonna have the energy
for that and sometimes you're kind of
just nervous and you want to focus on
what you got to do or whatever you know
but it's kind of part of the game you
know and and it does help the people
around you too mmm it's like okay he's
fired up okay maybe I'm not fired up now
but he's gonna get me fired up you know
and it kind of like helps the team yeah
but yeah so yeah sometimes it doesn't
feel that comfortable to do express
outwardly you know how passionate what
it helps Plus this fake like faking it
that's like a framing thing too you know
like you yeah you frame it like you're
faking it versus how you said you're
playing the game right you're playing
the game because you want to do a better
job yeah I want to get promoted you
wanna you want to get promoted for the
right reasons yeah there's nothing wrong
with that
yeah that's it yeah that's good I think
if you can kind of Bend and stretch
yourself in an uncomfortable way for the
benefit you know you know I think we're
people I think that term of faking it no
one wants to be a fake person right
right yes what just would you why you're
correct in that the way that's framed is
I'm being a fake person yeah and no one
wants to be a fake person yeah at the
same time you have to grow and you have
to adjust and if you're going to be in a
leadership position you're gonna do
things that you don't that you wouldn't
have planned I do that all the time I
mean when I was in the military you know
I worked with people that I've said this
before I work with people both below me
in the chain of command and up above me
in the chain of command that I despised
they never knew it they don't know who
they are right now what does that make
me a fake person no makes me a
professional makes me a professional at
doing my job because I wasn't gonna get
let some little personal emotion of mine
or some oh that guy's it does this and I
don't like that so I'm not gonna like
him and and now we have an adversarial
relationship and now I got a problem
ya know I'm playing the game play the
game so where's the line what is the
fake person genuinely well I was good as
you asked me what the line is the line
is if you go against what your
principles are yeah you know so if
you've got fundamental principles that
they say oh if you want this job of what
we needed you to do is fill out a report
about Billy saying that he did something
wrong that you know he didn't do wrong
mm-hmm right then you go no I'm not
gonna do that that
that that's what that's bad right
that's not now you're not just playing
the game now you're going against your
principles of being an honest person
about what's happening yeah this that's
really what it is right like the honesty
when you're a fake so like if someone's
like oh I'm faking it or I'm being a
fake person I said a fake person like
turning on some passion so manufactured
passion for the sake of the team and
stuff like that that doesn't feel like
you're a fake person fake person is kind
of like you'll sit like some I don't
know for example someone's in the room
and you're like hey you're great that
sure it looks great and you're doing a
great job they leave and be like that
guy sucks right don't know I'll tell you
the difference being the reason that
someone the reason that you would
consider someone would be angry that
someone's a fake person is when they are
doing it because they're doing it for
personal benefit they're saying like if
if if if you were my boss and I come in
and I say hey echo I really like your
new haircut it looks great mm-hmm I
don't really think that era coat looks
dumb but I'm gonna say that anyways and
everyone knows that all I want to do is
get that next promotion yeah that's
being fake
yeah that's being fake but if if I'm
saying because what am I really doing
what I'm doing is I'm making an
adaptation I'm growing I'm doing
something that I'm uncomfortable with
because I know it's gonna make me a
better leader mm-hmm well that's what I
should be doing is trying to become a
better leader yeah now again if that if
if in this whatever organization what
you have to do is is do something that
you don't agree with and it's it's the
wrong thing to do and you do it anyways
well then then that's that's that's
that's almost a totally different thing
there's that
then there's hey I'm gonna kiss ass so
that I get promoted it's all about me
mm-hmm
and that's probably the what we think of
the definition of a fake person yeah
[Music]